[Music]
like to welcome everybody here tonight
we're covering different chess tactics
those are ways to attack the opposing
position tonight we're going to go
different ways to attack the opposing
King now this first example we're going
to go through a couple examples on the
dangers of castling on the Queen side
you know the standard is to castle on
the Kings side it's generally considered
safer number one after you move your
King to scores to the right you're on
the king Knight 1 square behind the
three pawns when you Castle queenside
you're not on Queen Knight 1 you're on
Queen Bishop 1 and the King is not
behind the directly behind the three
pawns he's not protecting the Queen rook
pawn so when you Castle queenside it's
very common for the person who castles
Queen side to make another move with the
King to move over one Square to the left
to be on the knight queen Knight square
that's the safest position so now we're
going to look at some examples where
castling queenside will show you some of
the drawbacks that can happen so this
first position it's white to play and
win now to analyze any position first
let's look at the pawn position which is
quite simple there's three pawns on the
Queen side for both white and black and
three pawns on the Kings side and
they're on their original squares so
that means they're not in contact with
each other with pieces there are no pawn
moves to consider for the most part
once we look at the pawns now the you
it's good to look at the minor pieces
let's look at whites minor pieces White
has two bishops one on e3 and one on e
two when the bishops are side by side
they're very effective with each other
the white square Bishop covers the
diagonals on the white scores and the
black Bishop covers the adjacent black
diagonals now if we look at the bishops
you'll see right off the bat that the
white square bishop is aiming toward the
queen side and can hit the square be
five and a six now a six is defended by
a pawn but it's good to know and the
white squared bishop for white can move
to f3 and attack the b7 square it could
move to g4 and pin the knight on D seven
so you just kind of look at the possible
moves - these are the possibilities
white has to deal with now let's look at
the black square bishop on e3 for white
notice that it is aiming at that pawn on
a7 and remember I said when you cast the
Queen side that pawns not defended so it
looks like white might be able just to
snap that pawn off but as you know any
time you take a rook pawn your opponent
might block your bishop from retreating
by moving the pawn up to b6
so you have to consider that possibility
so much for the bishops
looking at the rooks the white work on
each one is behind a pawn and not doing
anything so we can disregard that work
for the time being now the work on d1 is
on an open file attacking the knight on
d7 and if the knight moves the RIC will
affect the other work on da
and notice that the rook keeps the black
king stuck on the queenside the black
king can't run to the king side because
the work cuts it off
also you should notice that if the
knight on D seven moves and black trades
works it doesn't buy black anything
because white just takes back with his
inactive work on h1 and replaces the d1
rook now the next thing you want to do
is look at the other side and see what
moves black hats we already said there
are no good black pawn moves let's look
at the Knights Black's Knights are on
the black second row that's very passive
the one knight move that might make
sense of black head the time would be to
play that night on e7 to f5 where he
would attack the Queen and the bishop he
could at least trade off one of the
bishops and that would price secure his
King side because white needs those two
bishops to have a successful attack so
if it was blacks move there's no doubt
he should play Knight to f5 and try to
safeguard his position by trading off a
minor piece the quote also the Queen the
black Queen is blocked by the knight on
e7 all the more reason to move it to f5
to open up the diagonal for the Queen
and notice that the Queen blocks that
rook on h8 keeps it from coming to the
middle of the board all in all white has
a strong position and in this case a
winning position so given all those
factors we talked about who would like
to propose a winning move for a white
yes Bishop takes a seven in this
particular case trying to block the
vision from retreating doesn't work very
well this is pretty simple black tries
to block the bishop but it opens up the
diagonal for the white bishop and it's
an immediate checkmate Bishop to a6 is
checkmate okay let's go on to the next
example
okay this is a similar to the previous
position the whites black squared bishop
in our prior example was on III
attacking the pawn in a seven now it's
on f4 and you'll notice right away that
black can't move his King because the
bishop guards all the black squares
that's very dangerous for black to have
a king immobilized like that the white
bishop on e - similar to the last
example is aiming to the a6 square where
at some point the bishop could move
there and if the bishop moves there
right away you would see it would be
attacking the pawn on b7 and if pawn
takes Bishop it would leave the c6 pawn
and protected Queen takes pawn check oh
that would be mate
checkmate wouldn't it so we'd have to
say Bishop to a6 is a possibility
wouldn't we well it turns out blacks
position is dire and white can win
within a couple moves there's actually a
stronger move than Bishop to a6 though
so that's called a red Harry and I threw
it out there it's not the right move
anyone see the winning move for white
yes Queen takes check the only way to
stop checkmate is to take the Queen and
it opens up that diagonal and Bishop to
a6 is checkmate similar to the checkmate
we looked at in the prior example so you
can see from here that sometimes
castling queenside is dangerous but we
also must take into consideration that
in both examples black's Knights were
not properly posted if the black knight
in this example was on c6 and the pawn
was back on c7 the pawn would block the
black the white bishop on f4 the black
squared bishop from and the king could
move to b8 the pawn on b7 would protect
the knight and the knight would protect
the paw and it would be much stronger so
it was kind of a setup for the author
made blacks position particularly bad
and in your own games it probably
wouldn't be so dire if you Castle
queenside all right well that's that
topic okay here's another exact 'uncle
so we'll do this we'll get the easy ones
out of the way first the topic is how to
bishops can attack a castle position so
let's look at that example well since I
just said the two bishops are attacking
welcome we're going over chess tactics
and how one side can attack the King on
the other side so these are little
examples the examples typically last
five two to eight moves and the topic of
this example is two bishops can attack
the opposing king side now if you look
at this position you can see that the
only side with two bishops is white
so it's white to play and win and notice
how the Queen and Bishop were on the
same of the bishop on b2 the Queen on c3
they're on the same diagonal and they're
aiming toward the black King now there
is a pawn on g7 and an American f6 but
the Queen and Bishop were attacking
along that line now when the Queen and
Bishop were lined up like that anyone
know what the chest term is what what is
it a battery yes so that is a battery
it's a very strong attacking formation
for white now it's not just the Queen
and the bishop on b2 but there's a
strong bishop on c4 attacking that white
diagonal toward the king and look that
diagonals open and the king is wedged in
the corner without being able to move
well that's definitely a possibility I
went through the example earlier but I
don't remember the exact move so we'll
take work to e8 under advisement let's
say let's start with that work to e8
threatening rook takes Queen your only
move is what for black and then what's
your follow-up and if the pawn takes
that's right let's find a better move
than pawn takes Queen if we can what do
you do if I move my cool let's see
I can't go to f8 I could go to e7 it's
protected by the knight what do you do
then I move the Queen to e7 to guard the
g7 square and prevent checkmate what
what do you do then as white
what's that weather the line we're
looking at is rook to e8 Queen takes
rook white does Queen takes rook now
we're moving the Queen up one squared at
E seven and what's the winning move now
for white oh okay well let's stick with
this until we get to the end well the
Queen temporarily stops checkmate right
but there's nothing blocking our pawn on
f5 is there our own Queen well we can
swap off the black Queen PS black has to
retreat the knight to a square where the
knight is undefended and we freed up our
pawn on f5 that's and we're still have
the bishop on that key line with the
king so the suggested move after Queen
takes Queen Knight takes Queen is what
to f6 and threaten two things pawn takes
Knight and pawn takes pawn which happens
to be checkmate yeah and if black does
pawn takes pawn you you have and that's
checkmate - so I don't see an answer to
that let's see if I think that's the
right solution so let's see yes you're
right very good Queen takes Queen takes
Queen here Oh
I think this is a case where white can
win two different ways pawn up
definitely wins this is an alternative
win the knight is unprotected it can't
move because that would let the rook go
to the eighth-ranked with check with
check
now if the knight moved to the eighth
right the RIC would go there
threatened rook takes Knight checkmate
because the bishop protects the knight
and black can't move his white his
bishop out of the way because it would
give up the rook so that's what happens
and there's no defense but pawn up the I
know the author said that would win -
okay now we're gonna have fun with this
topic there's a few more examples
smothered mate for examples some other
made is one of my favorite ways to
checkmate you wedge the King into the
corner and you lay checkmate with the
knight
so that's the idea this is very simple
so why don't you tell us what the right
move is yes white to play and get
smothered made in a few moves okay
King there now what
thank you
can the knight check the king alright
let's look at that the king has to move
over now you can double-check the king
six now if he goes to f8 Queen tough
seven is checkmate
here we go now what Hey and the rook
takes wedging the King in the corner and
we get our smothered mate very good
let's look at the next example
okay there's not an immediate smothered
mate here it takes a few moves to get to
it there is a winning move though who
would like to suggest the winning move
for white right check at a minimum right
off the bat we can win the rook for a
knight right and then we will attack the
Queen so the only way to he needs to
move move the King up to d7 so the other
rook when I do when white does Knight
takes rook check he wants to be able to
take back with the rook and he loses a
rook for a knight but he doesn't lose
the Queen so he does that there's a
stronger move the knight takes rook
check what's the right move for White
Knight takes what of the bishops I see
five yes the pawns pin so it doesn't
protect the bishop now the King has to
move now if the King moved back to d8 we
just drop her knight back in get the
fork and take the rook and we would have
won a piece in a rush yeah Queen e6
check now all the King moves over what
do we do now
d7 and he can't do Knight takes because
it would leave the Queen hanging
he moves the king over yeah oh well
first we take this night this is kind of
cute
there's no rush to get our smothered
mate we need to take that night because
we're going to do smothered mate with
the Knight to d7 check see so that's why
we take the knight first the King moves
over we drop the knight back now we can
do b6 double check and we have our
smothered mate setup rook takes yeah
that's nice I'd like to play that
against somebody okay obviously White
has the attacking chances okay you're
right King back now what b3 d5 the
knight could take it
b3 check works though now he could give
it up but we take we win a rook and we
threaten Queen FA mate and he can't move
the bishop by the way he can't really
defend the mate so he moves this king
over setting up our smothered mate okay
let's see what this one look this one's
a little trickier you're gonna have to
work harder hold on a second I got to
get rid of rid of that notation okay I
hope you didn't see it
what's the winning move for white
you did see it did you see the follow-up
what's the follow-up move when IG six I
just do pawn takes Knight
well we have a half hour bishop where
yes bishop g6 pawn takes Knight takes
pawn check wins the Queen so now the
threat is what's the whites threat now
if Y could make two moves in a row
Knight takes pawn check isn't really a
threat rook takes Knight Bishop takes
Queen takes would get two pieces for a
pawn and rickets
would be an even trade and White's
attack would be over what's the real
threat for white
well how about Bishop takes Knight
number one winning a piece number two
well anyway that's number one so black
retreats the knight he can't protect it
can he not well anyway he could move his
queen up but that would leave the f7
pawn unprotected and allow Knight or
Bishop takes pawn so he retreats now
what's the winning move for white
Bishop takes pawn very good he can't do
rook takes because we get the night fork
on the Queen and King so he moves the
Queen out now what do we do
King up now what
how about Knight takes f8 double-check
forcing the King back now what do we do
Queen h7 Knight takes Queen and what's
that checkmate
that was fun that was the end of my
sparse mother made examples but I
enjoyed that okay we have made on the
back rank made on the back rank there's
a lot of these so I saved it for last
there's about 14 examples we may not get
through them all but some of them are
very simple so I mean exceedingly simple
so we'll go through them real quick
white to play and win yes all right
that's the basic idea that's the author
knows it's simple he just wanted to lay
out the idea of an improperly defended
back ranked by black right so let's go
on to the next example pretty simple to
what no this one's a little harder
what's the winning move for white
there's no sacrifice or beautiful wind
but there is a very strong move
attacking move for white what would
could that be not f4 you mean e six well
just rook takes back and then what do
you do
notice that black is defending his pawns
are on white squares right we have both
of the white rooks attacking the pawn
how can we attack that pawn on d5 c4
that's the key move
now now what's the follow-up move let's
look at it
notice the D files open for the Queen so
the Queen can go to d8 at some point how
about Queen first now what does black do
with the work or the Queen now what's
the winning move Queen takes Queen bingo
so that was a little harder let's go to
the next guy okay so we see White is
attacking the Queen and Bishop are
attacking the knight on c6 it looks like
the knight is adequately defended by the
other night on e7 and the Queen on d5
well wait wait wait wait notice that the
Queen on d5 and the rook on d8 are open
on an open file that we can attack with
our one of our works driving the Queen
away the Queen can't take it because
that's defended by the rook and Queen
what's the winning move
Bishop takes here you guys have created
a variation that the author didn't have
let's see if black has a deep what could
black do well let's try the knight now
what does white do which work okay now
where can we move the Queen if anywhere
or are there any other moves well I
don't want to leave the Queen there
where it takes Queen where it takes rook
and I lost my queen hey how about this
the Queen protects the rook and oh it
takes the Queen then what oh yeah and
this doesn't work either does it
very good
all right all right so that didn't work
I wonder if there's anything else I can
do
let me think about this be six okay
let's try that anybody see a good move
for White Queen takes c6 okay now what
happens well what what do you think work
takes d1 work takes now what okay wait
wait wait wait okay now what yeah let's
go back a little bit okay so here we
went he know we tried queen east six
let's do that again now what did we do
oh we did Queen takes let's look at that
now pawn takes didn't work to extract
didn't work in pawn takes trick didn't
work and obviously Queen takes doesn't
work is there any other move how about
Bishop up here does that do anything he
what does a white do oh you could take
the bishop couldn't you
no but then the Queen would oh you take
with the Queen right you take with the
Queen no that won't work I got two
pieces on the Queen looks to me like
Bishop to d7 saves black let's go back
let's see what the author says first
move is the rook move now the Queen here
now we take take Oh Queen takes but oh
they okay so this is it but we said we
need to we need to find a solution to
Bishop here don't we oh I know what we
do we don't do anything fancy how how
about Queen takes pawn now we have a
pawn advantage and we have the two rooks
attacking this would probably win the
game it's not showy but it would
probably win it's there it's there a
better move for white than Queen takes
pawn I don't see one so I think Queen
takes pawn wins what do you think
yeah and the bishop on d7 blocks the
work on d8 so that's not good for black
either the only chance black oh and
notice oh we forgot White's a piece up
so he black staved off checkmate but
he's a pawn and a piece down so he's
lost anyway all right let's go to the
next one this is easy oh this is not a
win this is an example that's not a win
yes that's the defense actually this is
an even position there's no way for
white to win the game the author just
throws it in there to caution you that
sometimes there's a defense by the one
work retreating that and defends the
other work so it's it's it's not much of
an example but okay what do we have here
it looks to me that black has the
attacking chance here he has the two
works on the D file White's work on h4
is not supported by anything and the
bishop on f4 is not doing anything well
the only thing it does it keeps from
work to d2 it's black to move and win
what's blacks winning move
look what is the White Queen defending
there's two threats the White Queen is
defending what are they
no the White Queen is on e - what's it
defending from e - its preventing work
to D one check that's one what else is
it defending F - what else B - can the
Queen defend B 2 and D 1 at the same
time it's an overworked Queen you've
heard that phrase yes Queen takes B 2
drawing the Queen away from the D 1
square bingo yes exactly
okay let's see what we have next let's
see oh you saw that Bishop h6 what does
Queen takes now what and then what let's
see Oh pawn takes it's checkmate work
takes trick and that's the end of it
okay well you got that down
okay what's White's moved then let me
see what the first move is Knight takes
pawn it is black to win and then Rick
would come down the e1 check forking and
winning the Queen oh wait look we don't
we have a great move for white what does
black do now what what take the Queen
wait
oh there's checkmate so what's the right
move for black there is no right move
white wins black had a stunning deep
right had a stunning defense blocking
the checkmate with the bishop and
threatening his own checkmate black have
abandoned his back row when he did rook
to e1 check well work to e8 white has an
extra piece write an e as rook takes g7
pawn with a strong attack yeah yeah I
forgot about that too wait a minute
there is no win in this position it
depends on black making a bad move I
have to make a bad move this is an even
position in fact black has a slight
advantage
why does black have a slight advantage
the pawns and pieces are all offsetting
each other
exactly whites palm position is worse
that gives black a slight advantage but
the author has black make a bad move and
then you can figure out the wind knight
here now actually black can still get a
draw
he lost his advantage with this move
what does white do what's the whites
move yeah oh go ahead what is it d8 you
mean well then black could do Queen
takes back and threaten Queen takes
Queen and the work would continue to
protect that oh that would leave the
bishop you're right you're right okay
okay no if rook takes rook on d8 notice
black can do Knight takes bishop check
gaining a move and then he can take back
and white doesn't have a threat of
Bishop takes Bishop any longer so what's
the move for white I think we need to
gain a temple how can white gain a
temple white hat Bishop is attacked he
has to either move the bishop or take
something with the bishop that's the
right move Bishop takes wait wait wait
let's not jump to conclusions there is a
good a defense here that works for black
what is the right defense for black
No Oh Knight to f3 doesn't work cuz the
bishop can come back and take the knight
No
see the problem with Queen takes bishop
we leave our rook under protected and
white justice rook takes rook and if
work takes rook we have Queen takes your
achievement can we block that white
diagonal what's somehow can't we block
the White Queen diagonal with something
besides a knight the White Queen
diagonal from g5 to d8 how can we block
that diagonal with a move how about
moving our pawn up one square the defect
the correct defense is moving the pawn
up we gain a temple by attacking the
Queen and the Queen moves we take the
bishop and the Queen is no longer on the
rook you see there's only a white work
on a black rook and the black works
defended by the other rook and Bishop to
d5 check doesn't do anything because we
do rook takes Bishop threatening pawn
takes Queen this is an this what black
could still get an even game if he
played this instead he did rook takes
Queen takes and oh that's that's pretty
rather than Rick down even stronger
squeen takes Knight right right okay now
all these that we've been going through
our by sig brick Terrace who wrote the
the game of chess book that's what we've
been going over now we're going to go
through a chest problem written by an
Italian game named Stowe she way back in
1962 he got a lot of prizes for his
problems checkmate in two moves how hard
can that be
white to move you find the key move for
white and every thing black tries
there's a checkmate so white to move
checkmate in two moves now let's analyze
just a little bit where okay let's look
at it here and here oh wait a minute
yeah that would be checkmate wouldn't it
wait a second oh let's yeah let's block
the check
now where's though a checkmate
want to go back okay try another move
what is it
rook to d4 let's look at it rook here
check okay
now how about if we move the King and
attack the work here what do you do
what's your checkmate move
well the bishop could check me on d2 if
the bishop checks me I'll do King takes
rook right so you white only has one
move to checkmate does anyone see a
checkmate
I don't let's go back try something else
now let me give you a clue on problems
the first move is usually not a check
that's too obvious so don't look for
look for some move that threatens
checkmate but doesn't involve the first
move being a check I think that's it
Queen c6 okay now the king is pretty
much trapped he can only go to a three
or a five let's go to a three what's the
checkmate move yeah here rook here work
here I could go I could go back here
right
Oh bishop here that looks like that
works wait a minute Oh bishop - wait a
second
Queen here oh we said key I have to move
my king yeah you said bishop there
that's the checkmate
that's pretty what's the checkmate here
one move checkmate this movie that pond
up really change anything so what's the
right move Bishop to d2 and yeah the
pawn move really didn't change anything
let's check me okay good
we have one more we have one minute left
okay white to move and checkmate this
will be our last example two moves
what's the right move for white where
this pawn okay
and you're threatening Queen - II -
checkmate I'm gonna advance here and
take a knight
what's the winning move i guard the
checkmate square e - with my knight work
f1 wait a minute I can go - yeah I heard
D - that's the winning move checkmate
so whoever found work takes pawn that is
definitely the right move let's go back
a little bit so now o it and if Queen if
I get a Queen what's the checkmate yeah
that's it so that was pretty pretty
straightforward you did a good job and
finding it that'll cover it for tonight
thanks for coming
[Music]